It's not just about where you're from.
It's about the changes that you are
very adamant about making from the
place that you grew up in.
You're very serious about your culture.
You're very serious about uplifting and
creating opportunities for your people,
especially in the place that you come
from. Right?
I want to see change here.
Was that a thing that was always there?
The I want to see change here was the
thing that was always there for me
initially because I didn't know any
better. It came from in front of the
camera. It came from like the images
that I wanted to see just because I had
I had seen them. I had grown up on
them. So I knew it was possible.
And so then when it was taken away,
when I was watching TV in like high
school and college, movies, I was like,
Where's all this stuff that I grew up
on? Like, you know, where are these
stories? And why is it just kind of the
same narrative that's being shown?
I know we're more than this.
And so like even creating was born out
of a frustration. And then when I did
that online and started making the
content, I was like, Oh, there are all
these other jobs.
And initially, it just came out from my
circle. These are the people I know.
And so they're helping me to make this.
They happen to be black because most of
my friends are black.
And then, you know, then by extension,
we were bringing on, you know, more
diverse crew.
And then then it wasn't until I would
work on for smaller things, other sets,
and I'd be like, D***, this is like.
I didn't realize how rare this is to
work with other people of color.
Like Hollywood is very, very white
behind the camera. And so then it
became like, well, if I get my own
show, like I still want to replicate
this because I see that it's a rarity.
And why not?
Because I can.
How did you figure it out, though? How
did you figure out the the development
space of Awkward Black Girl?
Like you said, you came up, you wanted
to act. You knew that that's what you
wanted to do. But a lot of people
struggle with, well, what's my entry?
You are a hot commodity.
Just in the next version of a thing.
This girl is a star.
Like, Oh, my God, you got to watch this
girl. Like, creating that and then
developing that. Like, where did that
understanding come from? Was that
college that gave you that knowledge?
Yeah, a little bit. I mean, not for
myself in particular, but like people
don't know about Awkward Black Girl was
like the third web series that I made.
It was the third attempt, and it's the
only one that I was in the first two
that I made, you know, I wrote and
directed them, edited them, all those
things, you know, that you're doing
when you're making online content
yourself. And, you know, the first one
I did do in college and that was
starring my friends and I loved the
response that that got just from
college to college.
And, you know, it was about being black
at Stanford called Dorm Diaries.
And that was like, oh, okay.
I made something that people like and
it's spreading beyond my friend group.
This is dope.
And I just made it online.
And then I still wanted to sell it to
TV. So I was trying to, like, reach
into my network to be like, Hey, I made
this show. People really like it
online. It's only like 500 to 1000
people. But you know, it's something.
And they didn't want it.
So then I created my second show after
that, and it was starring my brother
and his friend group.
And that was something that I took more
seriously online where I was like, I'm
gonna release it every week and build a
following there. And I started to learn
the tools of like, you know, you can't
make content that's too long online.
You have to catch people's attention,
you have to build it, you have to be
consistent. So I started developing
those skills. So by the time I did
Awkward Black Girl.
And put myself in it, even though I was
scared as hell to put myself in it.
Well, why why didn't you put yourself in
the other ones?
Well, by that time, I was just like, I
like to write and direct because I had
gone to a school that that, you know,
like the plays and stuff where I'd have
been. I went to a predominantly black
and Latino high school.
So like the plays were for us.
I was in all of those by the time I got
to college. It was a predominantly
white college like there are no roles.
They weren't making stuff for us, so I
had no interest in the same way.
And so it came like my directing and
writing came from like, Oh, I'm gonna
make it. I will create like a play that
features us or whatever it is.
And so by the time Awkward Black Girl
came around, I didn't want to feature
myself because I didn't have the same
confidence anymore. I've been working
with actors and also, you know, I had
someone else in mind like I wrote it
with somebody else in mind, and then
that person couldn't do it because she
was in law school.
I was in LA, she was in D.C.
and so I just felt like I was running
out of time. So I was like, Let.
So you said f*** it, i'll do it.
Yeah.